all right
what's up folks yep talking about an old
movie
i'm going back to the 70s again yeah
this is the one that won the patreon
poll overwhelmingly i mean this one just
like
laid waste to all the other choices and
i'm glad because i can't actually
believe that we haven't
got around to talking about this movie
yet because this is a [ __ ]
classic it's a good movie this is this
is like kind of this is a masterpiece
for its time
oh definitely yeah i mean easily easily
one of the best
movies of the 70s easily one of the best
sci-fi movies ever made
invasion of the bodies invasion of the
body snatchers and we're talking about
the 1978 version because
um there have actually been four uh
direct
adaptations of this um if you didn't
know it's actually based on a book
that came out in 1954 or 1955 by jack
finney
that was called an uh invasion or just
called the body snatchers
um i actually read the book a really
long time ago and
you know so they made a film in 1956
directed by don siegel
who would famously go on to direct dirty
harry
um and that one that one's good too i
actually like that one um
that one kind of has a more
50s suburbia idealized
either anti-communist or
anti-mccarthyist kind of
spin to it i feel like the one though
that came out in 1978
which is what we're talking about today
the one with uh donald sutherland
and leonard nimoy i kind of feel like
the this one is more
it's like less overtly political i think
it's like more generalized
yeah it's almost like a socio-cultural
kind of thing i talk about mass
movements
it's not some you know yeah it's kind of
kind of like an anti-group thing
and interestingly this movie debuted
like not that long after the jonestown
massacre so i think a lot of people kind
of saw it in that light too it was like
cult like any kind of cult like any kind
of conformity or anything like that
because i think the original novel um
you know jack finney came 40s like i
wasn't
you know i didn't have any particular
political agenda i was just talking
about
how scary it would be like if everyone
was kind of
you know uh sucked into this one mind
you know group thing kind of thing and
it's like you
you couldn't tell like who was uh your
enemy and who was your friend you know
what i mean so i i feel like that's a
really
you know and the fact that there have
been four adaptations just of that book
and there have been a bunch of other
movies that were sort of
similarly themed um it's just the theme
of everybody believes something you
don't believe in and they're taking over
yeah how do you survive and i feel like
you can relate to that and it's kind of
interesting i found this other video
um i can't remember the name of the
guy's channel but i'm subscribed to and
he has like a lot of really good like
film analysis
and he was he went through every single
adaptation
all four adaptations of uh invasion of
the body snatchers and he was talking
about how each of them like reflected
you know whatever the fears of whenever
it was made was
so it's really kind of an evergreen
story that you can sort of you can
reboot it differently you can reboot it
in different ways and like cash your own
uh
stuff on it interestingly i didn't know
i knew that there was one made in the
2000s with nicole kidman which was just
called the invasion
uh which i heard wasn't very good i
don't think i've seen it but i didn't
know until today that there was another
one
that was just called the body snatchers
that was made in 1993 that was directed
by abel ferreira of all people
and uh i heard that one wasn't all that
great either
although i like abel ferreira movies so
maybe i should i didn't even know he did
that one but
anyway so the but the 1978 one i think
is easily the best
adaptation of all the ones that they
have made
so and it's kind of like the best a la
alien one and john carpenter's the thing
it's in there
yeah it's like a paranoia yeah i really
really like
everything's really good one thing that
i i like a lot about 70s movies in
particular
uh and and this one too is that they
really have this kind of
man it's like it's hard to put your
finger on it's a feeling of alienation
through these damage
yeah it's all this one almost comes
across as like a little bit of a
conspiracy theory
yes conspiracy thriller type of thing
and i feel i've seen it compared to like
the parallax view or some other
movies like that that came out around
the same time period where everything is
just very isolating and [ __ ]
yeah one of the weird things jenny just
noticed is that
early on in the movie before the people
even know what the hell's going on
about an alien invasion in the
backgrounds in the crowd some of the
people are just standing there watching
the camera
yeah and it's like i never already
flipped
i never really noticed that before i
mean there's so many
like re-watching it again because i've
seen it several times but i haven't seen
it for
many years and re-watching it again for
this review
i was just struck by all of these subtle
little choices
that they made uh philip kaufman who
directed it
who he went on to do uh the right stuff
i think he did henry in june which is
another great movie unbearable lightness
of being some other ones
um but just him and the cinematographer
the way that they conveyed this just
awesome sense of like dread and paranoia
they almost did because i don't
think now i'd please correct me if i'm
wrong they shot this in san francisco um
because that's philip philip kaufman was
from there and that's like his favorite
city
and he just wanted to do a take on it
that was more like an
urban take rather than like the suburban
take from the original movie
and he's just like so they almost did
like a gorilla filmmaking
type of uh thing they didn't block off
the streets or anything like that
and um so it gives this real kind of
sense that the camera is just like
sneaking around like watching the people
yeah you know what i mean which i think
really really adds to like the
atmosphere yeah as the alien takeover
starts to unfold the main characters are
starting to suspect something might be
wrong
the chinese uh launderers guy comes up
and goes
my wife that's not my wife and they're
like what that's not my wife
it's just weird [ __ ] and then later on
they're in the car driving and a dude
runs up to them on traffic trying to
warn
them you know something's wrong they're
taking over they're taking and then a
rage mob
chases him down the street they're going
what the hell's going on then they drive
around and then they see him dead hit by
a car and they're all
standing around him like that like
emotionally yeah just like
started off with a dude trying to warn
you and a [ __ ] rage mob comes after
him
like twitter well that dude was like a
twitter mob
it was it was a call out because that
dude that's kevin mccarthy and he played
uh the main character in the original in
the 1956 movie yeah
and uh you know very iconically when he
was like you're next you're not
like right across the bridge yeah yeah
so i thought that was kind of like a
cool little homage almost like he'd been
running around trying to warn people
about the alien patient for like 22
years or whatever
it's like they're not listening to me
it's like the [ __ ] aliens are coming
but yeah i like too that you can't i
mean i feel like invasion of the body
snatchers it's one of those movies that
um even if you haven't seen it like i
think everybody knows the general
premise of it i mean everybody knows
what the pod people are and [ __ ] like
that so it's like that's where the
concept is
people are conformists yeah and go along
with what everybody else is saying
right and you you know and everyone has
had that feeling where you kind of feel
like
everybody is you know different from you
or you're like the odd one out or
whatever so i feel like everyone can
relate to it which like i said is why
there have been so
many adaptations you go down to downtown
clearwater the pod people are
scientologists
well i use when i worked for them i used
to call them the pod people not to their
faces but
you know that's that's what we all
called them like behind their backs
so yeah you could definitely see that as
a cult mentality and i think
the 70s one may be more than the 50s one
because like i said i feel like the 50s
one was
you know more politically based but the
one in the 70s i think was more
socio-cultural in the sense that
you know one thing that they that i
thought was really cool and i didn't
really realize it until i
rewatched this again because i haven't
seen it for a long a long time
i like that they cast everybody in the
cast donald sutherland brooke adams is
in this uh jeff goldblum
veronica cartwright you know who the
next year would go on to do alien
they cast these people that are like
kind of oddballs
yeah you know what i mean they're kind
of like socially awkward like some of
the conversations they have
are kind of weird and awkward jeff
goldblum booms in this and he's kind of
a [ __ ] outcast in a way
intellectually yeah
people don't like him so he kind of yeah
he's a poet the reason why they did that
is because they're going to tell you
that
people who didn't fit in in the
beginning are the first to see it
yeah well because it's almost kind of
like they're implying that those people
are more human
because they have all the human
frailties and human og
you know they're so there's they're
oddballs like even in the
context of their own society yeah well
they also understand
the uh the mass gestalt yeah because
they've been against it so they know it
real well when it changes they're the
first to notice it
yeah because they're not caught up in it
yeah they're outside of it which i
didn't really like that
now you said that this that the first
one was more political this one's more
social
it's actually all the same all right
[ __ ]
politics religion and social movements
are all
different in term different variations
of the same thing in human behavior it's
that damn
school like a like a like a school of
fish type mass
mentality that's exactly what they're
talking about it's all the same thing
communism
nazism all the big different types of
fascism they were all
mass movements you know essentially they
were all the same
and that's it didn't matter the
differences between the two they were
pretty much all the same that's what
this movie's about
just mass movements mass conformity
yeah it's a threat to individuality
that's what it means
yeah and that's why i think it was
really smart for the casting that they
did because the people that they cast
were very individual in the sense that
they were very distinctive looking they
were very distinctive acting
they weren't um you know like i said
they were kind of oddballs
even in the context of like a not alien
invasion
so they you know they were kind of like
left out of things a little bit they're
inferring that the oddballs because they
never fit in are the first to notice the
change
that's what they're talking about which
is exact exactly exactly what happens
yeah that's the way it is in real life
too it is true to life
yeah what they're talking about yeah so
brooke adams i think she's actually the
first one to notice because you don't
i love too that they're real subtle
about when the invasion starts i mean
the the open
the opening credits like while the
credits are rolling they actually do
which i had forgotten about but they
actually do show
like some other planet somewhere and
these um you know gelatinous
kind of micro microbial channels
essentially that's what they are um they
kind of show them like kind of bubbling
up on the planet and how they kind of
come down to the to the earth like it
you know in the form of rain and then
these like little weird
pod plants with these flowers plausible
man that's kind of like the mixture of
the andromeda strain
slither and the thing yeah that's all
that same
idea that aliens could travel the gulf
of space without spaceships
the first one that thought of that was
actually h.p lovecraft
yeah the old ones they just traveled
across space like spores
yeah on the cro riding the solar winds
which is way scarier because you'd never
know
because like i said they just showed
there's a shot at the beginning like i
think the one of the first shots of the
movie
is brook adams like looking out the
window and
you know it's raining and then they just
kind of show these close-up shots of
these little
gelatin things like on leaves like it
looks kind of like rain water but kind
of goopy
and then like little tendrils start
coming out i guess it affected plants
first and flowers and it made its own
version of a flower
and then it gets tendrils get on you and
you become like a pod and then
well actually it had to touch you for
it's kind of complicated uh it touches
you and steals your dna
makes a pod and a copy of you
pops out the copy pops out and you who
got
touched by the tendrils you're alive
until you fall asleep if you fall asleep
you never wake back up
your body just disintegrates like a
empty husk
yeah so once you get touched by those
things you can't sleep if you sleep
you'll die
yeah because it will take you over and
it doesn't i don't already did
it's that it's got something in you
remember as soon as they fell asleep
they just
fell apart like an empty husk that way
there's no original body
yeah to prove that you got copied which
that's
that's a brilliant evolutionary adapter
i mean the more you think about the
concept of this the [ __ ] scarier it
is
yeah because you would never know the
spread of them goes unnoticed by the
population that has not been affected
yeah but then there are a group
mentality kind of like the thing
out of the out of the out of the slither
they all know
who's flipped kinda i think they can
detect it but they're not psychic
because you can fool them because you
can fake it if you're naked
i mean they're essentially they when
they take over a person
they take over their you know mannerisms
their memories and stuff like that they
just
it's almost like the soul or the you
know the emotions they don't have any
emotions what they're talking about is
in eastern europe and in the communist
block back in the back of the time that
was from this first um
story first came about there were people
in the communist
sphere of the world faking it they
didn't believe it but they had to fake
it that's kind of what they're talking
about
yeah because you're going to get your
ass killed if you don't go along with
the
yeah which like i said everyone can
relate to that
so it's kind of like so another thing
that i love too because you mentioned
earlier
that one of the things i noticed not
only is the
cinematography of this um just the way
it's shot they have like these strange
there's like dutch angles there's all
like stuff is shot from just like
bizarre angles sometimes
not to a point where it's distracting
but i also love too the way
stuff is shot like down these dark
corridors like it's almost shot like a
noir film
but in color you know what i mean that
was kind of one of the things they were
going for
and like i said before even before you
know anything weird is going on
um you know you can see people in the
background like people will be milling
around
acting normal but then they'll be like a
group of like three people that are just
like staring
either at the camera or at the
characters
and also i didn't notice this either but
there's also
several shots of people standing by
garbage trucks and in their dumpsters
and inside the garbage trucks and
dumpsters
is like this gray fluff which you find
out later is the husks
of the old bodies you know what i mean
so like the the pod people
after they've duplicated the person and
the other and the
uh you know the the original host body
has disintegrated
they kind of just throw it out with the
garbage and it has been so it's been
there the whole time
and you didn't realize it yeah so like
the main characters don't realize
until brooke adams character because her
and donald sutherland are co-workers
yeah they work at the health department
she's more like a botany kind of person
and he's kind of does like in
restaurant inspections and [ __ ] like
that and um
she notices she picks up one of the
flowers because it's you know she's like
i said she's
botanist and she she's never seen one
like it before and she thinks it's like
really pretty and it smells really good
so she takes it home because she wants
to study it and leaves it on the bed
next to her uh on the her boyfriend's
side of the bed
and then when she wakes up the next
morning uh the flower's gone
uh the glass is broken and her
boyfriend's acting real
weird yeah like he's acting like real
just just very cold and distant like
they can still talk and
like i said they still have all the same
memories and everything but they're just
very
deadpan the thing that i really liked
about the movie is that
one of the main characters is jeff
goldblum
and he's working he's living and working
in kind of a jewish neighborhood
and he's working at a spa jewish guys
are going to it
and uh he kind of has it a
not an enemy but uh what would you call
it a competitor he doesn't like who's
leonard de moy he's another jewish guy
and they're both
authors yeah and they
and goldblum can't stand this dude just
disagrees with him constantly
goldblum is the first one to notice the
invasion
and and the nemoy character he doesn't
see it but over time through logic a
reason i guess he kind of becomes
spock-like
the nemoy character says i believe you
even though i don't have evidence
so he kind of makes that did you notice
that kind of makes the
leap into faith to believe although
by that point he uh leonard de moy has
already been
oh you integrated i didn't notice that
actually you don't
know i know it was before that point but
you don't know
actually leonard nimoy could have been a
pod person from the beginning
although there was kind of um i think
there was a scene where he laughed and
[ __ ] like that which that wouldn't have
wouldn't have flown um but the thing
well the thing that's fascinating about
leonard nimoy's character
um i love that philip kaufman wanted him
in this movie because
he's like you know obviously he got
typecast as spock and he's like i really
wanted to kind of
you know try to fight against that but
he also wanted to use the spot character
you know to inform the movie as well
because you know
obviously it seemed like since everyone
was kind of emotionless toward the end
it was almost like a spotlight kind of
thing
but leonard namoy he's like a pop
psychiatrist
yeah he has this thing which is all the
rage in like the late 70s i guess it was
like shock therapy and
some of the stuff he said seemed
reasonable but some of the stuff was
kind of
nutty and that was one of the reasons
why jeff goldblum's character didn't
didn't love him all that much because he
said oh you know all his
views he has her like crap but he had he
was a best-selling author
yeah and he was trying from the
beginning he kept having these
women largely that had read his books
and they kept coming to him going hey my
husband
isn't my husband anymore even though he
looks exactly the same but
he's not the same and he started to like
rationalize it it was like a massive
psychosis
and it's like oh well this is just you
women like you want to get out of the
relationship
and so you're trying to like make up
yeah this thing that it's like it's not
he's not the same person anymore that's
just it's you
um so so like i said you don't actually
know
um from the outside like when he got
turned
because that conversation that you're
talking about later on again where he go
where they're at the top of the building
and he says uh to to donald sutherland's
character he says i believe you because
i've known you for such a long time
he's already okay he's already turned by
that point because as soon as he leaves
that meeting
he goes down and gets in a car with some
of the other podcasts okay see the
reason
the reason why i the reason why i
compared it to the thing is because that
shit's going on a lot you're not really
sure who's flipped or not
yeah i can go back and watch the thing
and it's
there are some guys i said he must be
the thing that one you can watch it over
and over again you're trying to
remember who was wearing what clothes
how much time have passed by that which
is kind of what you're doing in this one
it makes you super paranoid it's like
really dreaded dude yeah
but i did like the fact that because
you know because the director and the
guys were starring at the in the time
the jewish guy recognizes it first
because they were the outsiders in
in in in mainstream society in the 70s
that's what they're talking about
and there was like a new breed of uh
jewish directors in hollywood that were
coming up and they were they were making
good money spielberg and
you know and lucas were just right
around the corner this is what 1977
78 78 okay so they were lucas and number
were already in the game and that they
so that's that's what they that's why
it's goldberg and that's why it took
place in that neighborhood and
everything i i thought it was a good
touch
well yeah like i said because and like i
said all the characters too i mean
brooke adams i guess
everybody was an outsider brooke adams
technically was the first one to notice
because she noticed the flower and then
she noticed her boyfriend acting weird
but the thing about her was that she was
kind of quirky as well like that weird
[ __ ] [ __ ] she does with her eyes
yeah yeah which i guess that's like yeah
it was pretty freaky yeah that's that's
a girl from um
uh if you guys she was in the dead dead
zone yeah yeah later
yeah i mean she was in a bunch of i
think she's this might have been her
first
major film role i think she did tv prior
to this if i'm not mistaken but yeah she
was in like a lot of movies in the 80s
um but yeah so and like i said veronica
cartwright was uh in this as well
because her and
uh jeff goldblum were like they ran like
a spa so
they were almost kind of like they
weren't hippies but they were kind of
like
new agey yeah type of people you know
what i mean
so yeah so there was that whole thing
going on so as as the story goes on
it's creepy too because at first
everybody's like you know
yeah my you know significant other isn't
my significant other anymore and
everybody just kind of thinks it's a
mass delusion at first but then like a
few days after that
some of the people that were saying that
kind of came out are like oh just
forget it like chinese guy did that yeah
it's like oh not my wife that's not my
wife
but then a couple days later he's like
oh i don't know no problem yeah [ __ ]
that's my
yeah so obviously he's been integrated
as well
so it gets to a point where uh you know
everything starts closing in it's like
one of the creepiest scenes
is where donald sutherland is like
trying because you know they start
finding uh you know some of the
partially formed pod people jeff
goldblum actually finds they find one in
the mud baths
that's starting to look like him so
that's kind of why they figure it out
and then uh
elizabeth you know burke adams's
character she
um she kind of starts to get integrated
as well
that's the part i didn't understand
though they found the one that was
looking like
jeff goldberg did he sleep after that no
he fell asleep but then he woke up
okay he fell asleep for a second and
then his pod person
opened its eyes because remember uh
veronica cartwright was like i saw it it
opened its eyes it took his eyes
um but then when he woke up it was
inevitable anyway because you can't go
without sleep forever
well that's what i was saying and i was
like and i think i think they kind of
went into this more in like the 90s
version in the later version
there's like there would really be no
way to fight this interestingly the 50s
version
had kind of like a [ __ ] cop-out
ending because i guess it had more of a
you know more of like an ending like
this one had in the 50s one originally
where it was just kind of because like i
said you would never be able to
fight an invasion like that um because
one you got to sleep sometime
uh two it's you wouldn't know like who
to trust
so it would just be what they would call
a soft invasion
so there wouldn't be any way to fight it
but in the original movie they were like
the studios were like no
you know it's the 50s we can't have that
bummer of an ending where
so they had to have a little bit of hope
at the end but this one
uh you know the 70s they were all about
the nihilistic endings and this
definitely has one of the best
ending twists of any movie i've seen you
know what i mean well you wouldn't be
able to fight this
that's what i mean same as the thing you
wouldn't be able to fight the thing yeah
i mean it's so [ __ ] great they go
through all of this [ __ ] where it's like
poor
um you know poor donald sutherland it's
like him
and uh his girlfriend elizabeth are like
running away from the [ __ ]
she falls asleep finally because like i
said as you would you need to sleep
sometime and that's when the pods are
gonna get you
and there's so many [ __ ] pots they
see this massive warehouse
they're growing them they're like
putting them on ships
they're gonna you know send them out
worldwide and it's gonna like [ __ ]
take over so
you know even though it's probably a
futile of futile effort
um you know he's like he has to have to
fight against it somehow so he goes into
the thing and like burns it down
all it takes is a couple people in
authority to become a pod people and
that's right well and that's what
happened
is that you know about the halfway point
of the movie or maybe a little bit past
you know donald sutherland is like hey
we're finding all these bodies or i need
to help elizabeth and this is kind of
before he realized the extent
uh you know of of the invasion how far
it progressed
because every time he calls like the
cops or something they already know his
name and it's like and then he figures
out that the more he calls to try and
report
[ __ ] like that's how they're that's how
they find him you know what i mean so
they're just tracking them down his name
yeah group yeah mr bonnell and he's like
wait i didn't tell you my name what the
[ __ ] and
jeff goldblum's like hang it up oh my
god they're trying to find us
but uh yeah so so he burns the the thing
down
but while he's doing that uh elizabeth
falls asleep
and gets turned into a pod person which
is a great i love that effect where he's
like
hugging her and her face starts like
collapsing and then like she and then
like the
pod person pops up all naked and she's
running around naked and stuff
um but yeah so he goes through all that
you think he's the only one left um
because at one point like jeff goldblum
and veronica cartwright's characters
i can't remember their character names
look man jeff is skinny as [ __ ] in this
just he's super tall although
but yeah he's very gangly he looked like
a scarecrow in this [ __ ] man it's a dude
you need to eat eat your sandwich
well he bulked out a bit later because
like i said this was literally that this
was probably like
annie's what was this like eight years
before the fly he had bulked out quite a
bit for that one because he worked out a
lot for the flag because he had to do
all that
you know acrobatic [ __ ] but um but yeah
so they go through all this trouble
you don't know i mean jeff goldblum you
find out that he got uh integrated
because
you know he him and veronica
cartwright's character they took off
like to distract
and while they were so you don't know
what happened to them jeff goldblum
turns up later on and then veronica
cartwright turns up later on and she
hasn't been
integrated and she's the one that tells
them hey you know i've been walking
around with them you can fool them
if you just walk around and you act like
you don't have any emotions
and just kind of like follow them and do
what they tell you
um so she's been kind of like incognito
but then what happens it's almost kind
of like in walking dead back in the old
days when they used to like
put the zombie guts all over themselves
and like walk among the zombies
so it's kind of like that but then when
they're doing that
um they one i think it's uh
elizabeth she like freaks out because
she sees that dog with the
with the person head which is one of the
most iconic images from this
and you know it looks good it really
does and it's like it's so so creepy i
don't know how it's real looking i don't
know either actually i didn't i went on
the wikipedia page but it didn't really
it was very vague
about how they did it um it looked like
it might have been a photograph
superimposed on a dog but it's dog yeah
it's like tongue came out though
it's like i don't know it was really
weird it looks really
disturbing i mean still and it was like
1978.
yeah it was pretty it looked good pretty
cool but i had forgotten the problem
effects are good on this too they really
are and this movie only costs like three
or four million dollars to make
you could see kind of like the
beginnings of you know like alien
and aliens yeah and all that kind of
stuff coming you know they would be
good good special effects yeah that's
what spielberg would do yeah i mean like
when the
when the pod people are you know when
they're coming out of the pods like the
one
you know when donald sutherland falls
asleep and they start podding out and
everything that looks [ __ ] great
still and that's like i said it's 1978.
all practical effects
and they did them really cheap i mean
they did them on the cheap but it does
not look like it
because like i said they only had three
or four million dollars to make this and
they wanted all these you know all the
all the actors that they wanted to be in
it you know that was
like a lot of the budget so they didn't
really have a lot of budget for special
effects but you would never guess it
but yeah so the dog thing i had
forgotten i just thought that dog was
just like a weird random thing
but there was actually a scene
explaining where that came from because
it was the banjo guy
oh fun fact that the banjo like in the
movie that was played by uh
jerry garcia that was he wasn't in the
movie but he was the one playing the
banjo
um but yeah so the so the guy and the
dog they showed them earlier on
and then at one point when he was bummed
right yeah when when donald sutherland
and then she's yeah it's like a street
uh street performer or whatever he was
and um when donald sutherland and uh and
brooke adams are like running away
they see him and the dog sleeping next
to one another and then there's pods
and then i guess he like donald trump
like kicks one of the pods or like
breaks it
so i guess at some point like one pod
took over both of the things got
confused and it got confused it was like
a brundlefly moment yes
so it's like so i was like oh i've
forgotten that they referred to that
i didn't realize that the dog could be
absorbed well i guess it would be any
any any living living thing because
another thing that i didn't notice too
until i watched it again was that the
score of the movie
which the guy that did the score this is
the only movie he ever scored
he wasn't like yeah he did um if you
notice like the
the sound at the beginning of the movie
you know you can hear city noises and
stuff like garbage trucks and whatnot
but you can also hear like birds and
stuff
as the movie goes on all the natural
sounds leave
okay and so you know so by the end of
the movie it's all those weird like
unnatural
machine like noises and also the
screeches like from the aliens and
whatnot
but like i said i think this this movie
easily one of the
you know easily easily one of the best
sci-fi movies ever one of the best
movies of the 70s
and like i said that [ __ ] iconic
ending where
you're not sure because they cut away
from donald sutherland
after um elizabeth dies and
he's back in his office and everybody's
in the office everybody's doing their
regular [ __ ] like their regular job like
they would but they don't
you know they're not making any jokes or
hanging out or anything they're just
being all
pod people and so you don't know for a
second if donald sutherland is like
faking it
you know and he's still him but then you
know he's out in the street and there's
all these weird like
dead trees and [ __ ] that score that you
were talking about at the time i
to me it sounded like a cronenberg sound
it did a bit yeah
it did a bit math sounds like
cronenberg's work yeah
and you can see because like i said this
is a little bit of a kind of a body
horror thing too
yeah but um but yeah so so then donald
sutherland he sees veronica cartwright
and veronica cartwright has not been
integrated because she's been faking it
like however long it's been i guess it's
just been
a day or two and she's all excited
because she's like
oh boy you know it's donald trump it's
another normal person
and then he turns around and there's
that really scary like that pregnant
pause
and then he goes and you're like oh [ __ ]
she's the only one left it's like so
[ __ ] scary
it's just such a great [ __ ] scene but
yeah
so uh where we watched this on
youtube i think it's free on youtube
oh that was youtube okay if i'm or it
might be to be but we watched it
we watched it for free okay um i think
it was free on youtube and
honestly i think some of the other
versions are on there too
um i think the 1956 version which is
worth watching
uh let's see i think this is the best
adaptation
of that book um just i don't know
everything about this one came together
for me i love
the cinematography i love how just it
makes you
paranoid and it's just like it's so it's
dread inducing just the way that it's
shot
it just feels so like like you're being
watched all the time well they're riding
around these 70s cars looking out the
windows going you know going
what's going on what's wrong with you
know it's just because it's a small
group of people and
slowly the world is turning against them
you kind of do have that feeling
yeah and it's everything is like kind of
a skew yeah little details people in the
background watching them
stuff as they go by and looking at the
camera
just weird i love that and i don't think
i even noticed that the first time that
i
watched it but this time it was like
really apparent like they
they'd be going down a hall at their
work and there'd be a guy looking out of
the pebbled glass like looking at them
like in the background
yes i loved that at the spa the bearded
dude that came out there you know
remember the jewish guy that was talking
to
were they trying to insinuate that he
was already he had already flipped
see i think so yeah because he was
staring at her and he goes you're very
smart
yeah i'm pretty sure that guy that guy
was supposed to already
i would i could be mistaken but i think
that was don siegel the guy that
directed the
1950s one i think there's a lot of
cameos in this
oh robert duvall was uh uncredited
uncredited
well he was he just happened to be in
san francisco and they were like hey can
you be in here from he's like yeah i'll
do it play as a priest on the swing set
which is one of the creepiest because
she just like finds the flower in the
park like at the very beginning of the
movie and he's looking at you and he's
looking at you
and he's like on the swing like with all
these little kids and priests and little
kids you know
yeah that's never look at that but it's
like just little details like that that
just kind of
unsettle you like right from the
beginning it's just like a brilliant i
mean it's a brilliant piece of
filmmaking just the way that it
uh goes but yeah seriously pretty sure
it's free on youtube or it's free
somewhere
um but yeah this is the the best the
book's good too
uh this did a lot of different [ __ ] with
it
but if you're gonna see any adaptations
see this one the 50s one is good too
that would be the s the second one i
would recommend
this is better yeah this one's better i
just think it's more broadly it has more
broad appeal
i think it's more of like a
generalization it's better that too
and it definitely has that creepy 70s
kind of vibe to it close encounters of
the third kind gone wrong
kind of feeling yeah much i like that
one too
yeah we you know what we haven't done
that one have we holy crap we need to
review that one too yeah
but yeah uh definitely check it out if
you haven't seen it
and uh we will see you on the next one
bye